(groovy music)
- All right y'all.
Boop!
(laughing)
I want to share one
last tidbit of goodness
before we wrap up this hour.
This is "What I'm Liking" Lester.
(groovy music)
(crowd cheering)
Listen, the pandemic has been hard
and few have had it harder than nurses.
That's what makes this
story such a bright spot.
When Kelsey, an ER nurse in Georgia,
got called up to the
hospital's rooftop helipad
she had no idea what would be in store.
She obviously assumed it would
be a pickup for a patient,
a logical guess or assumption,
but nope, it was something else entirely.
And the hospital staff,
actually they captured this.
So watch this.
(staff cheering)
- [Woman] Oh my God!
(staff crying)
Oh, they are so nice.
(staff cheering)
(crowd cheering)
- Kelsey's boyfriend, Jacob, proposed
and she said yes.
That would've been awkward if she hadn't.
We have them on the line right now.
What's up y'all?
How are you doing Kelsey and Jacob?
So you're both nurses
and you met on the job.
So thank you, first of
all, for being nurses.
(crowd cheering)
Thank you so much.
- Of course.
- And y'all met on the job, right?
- Yes, so I was a new grad
coming out of nursing school
and trying to decide
where I was gonna work at
and I interviewed at
Kennestone and they said
why don't you come shadow
on trauma for a night
and just see how you like it.
And they were smart putting
me with Jake for a night.
And on our very first evening together
we got to go up to the helipad
and that's why it was really special
for years later, after
everything we've been through
and how much we've
grown and fallen in love
and everything else.
For him to propose on the same helipad,
it was just a really sweet
full-circle moment for us.
- Yes, I mean working with
my best friend is amazing,
especially in such a tough
time like the pandemic.
It's very stressful.
But being able to go to work
and come home with my best friend
and kind of wind down is amazing.
(crowd cheering)
- Aww.
I love y'all.
I love love.
So what were you thinking Kelsey
when you realized he was proposing?
- Um, honestly it took me
a second to even figure out
that's what he was doing.
I was in shock completely.
His biggest goal was to make me surprised
and boy did he achieve it.
And he had it arranged
where our managers had us
off for the rest of the day
so we could go celebrate
with our friends and family.
- [Kelly] Oh man.
Well Jacob,
(crowd clapping)
you are a straight up baller.
Arriving helicopter, proposing.
I'm like wait what?
Like men everywhere right now are like
are you fricking serious?
I got to arrive on a helicopter.
That's amazing.
Were you nervous at all
or were you just excited?
- Kelly, you couldn't imagine
how much stress went into this bad boy.
I mean, head to toe full body sweats.
Um...
(Kelly laughing)
So I had to make a fake patient
out of pillows and blankets.
I had to get the manager
team and the nurses
to all pretend that we're
in separate sections
and all that good stuff.
And the whole time, the helicopter,
it's an active helicopter.
So like if a 9-1-1 emergency gets called
whole plan's over with.
We go somewhere else, you know?
So,
stressful,
most stressful day of my entire life.
But when I finally asked and she said yes
it was the best day of my life for sure.
- [Kelly] That's totally worth it.
You two are adorable!
(crowd clapping)
Thank you so much Kelsey and Jake.
And again, congratulations.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
- [Kelsey] Of course!
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much!
This is crazy.
(bell dinging)
- [Kelly] Well that's not all.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show",
want to honor ultimate overachievers
and you're arriving in a
helicopter man, so that's you.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
How does that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- That's awesome!
Thank you so much.
That's amazing.
- Thank you!
- Thank you.
- Weddings are expensive.
Thank you (laughing).
- Thank you guys!
Congrats and good luck!
(crowd cheering)